so the question of the day today is see
through your question yeah I know
I think what's the topic pause let it
sink let them absorb the Alex words
talking too much I'm gonna forget the
lines okay I got good morning believe
nation today's message is think for
yourself over to you Russell Brand truth
is a powerful us land you know we will
go our own personal troops then there
are certain principles they'll help
align us all just be true to your
essential self don't I cover people over
now pod that yeah he's be annoying Tesco
he's Joe I think's really important it's
like you don't like say when I was a kid
it was all like apartheid and all that
stuff and also would pretend to be sort
of angry about here and obviously I
agree with complete racial integration
and racial Kali but actually when I was
at home at night I won't actually I
think real people who are plenty of
particle sleep you know me really like I
say when I got ripped off like a bus
driver wouldn't give me my fare back or
when there's an ATM charge of 350 I'm
prepared and I'm kill Oh an apple change
their charger charges for you know that
stuff really affects me and impacts me
you know so what I think we have to do
is recognize where in our own lives
we've been ripped off with them ripping
us off left them right you know like
we've recognized where those things are
I recognize that those things are not
necessary and when people tell you
they're there is no alternative look at
the people who are telling you that
there's no alternative to this system
that happens to benefit me all those
[ __ ] convenien we've looked at all
the alternatives and the best one is me
in a big castle
oh thanks well they'll stop thinking
debate over so what do you think I'm a
strong believer in getting other
people's opinions before I make serious
decisions in my life but the final
decision and ownership always comes down
to me I think that whether you make a
good choice or bad choice a mistake
something you know opportunity to grow
you should always take ownership of your
decisions it shouldn't never be well I
spoke to this person they told me to do
this and that's why I did it so in that
line you really do have to think for
yourself and you have to accept the fact
that the only way to grow is to take
ownership of all your decisions whatever
they are so just a kind of counterpoint
with that I think it's good to use other
people's feedback as a counselor but not
a jailer where often we are trapped in a
box that we've been put into by other
people right and we try to live up to
their expectations like oh my mom wants
me to do this or my friends think I
should go here my professor thinks I
should do this or my friends will laugh
at me if I try to do that and then you
don't take the chance that you want to
take because you've let them lock
yourself in and I think too many people
then blame others or blame their
environment or blame their government or
blame the tax rate or blame their
country or whatever right you put blame
anywhere else except on you right and
it's not until you accept the
responsibility that you can change
everything you can change your routine
you can change your habits you can
change your environment you can change
your circumstances when you fully
believe that you are in control and stop
blaming others that's when the magic
starts to happen so the question of the
day today is how do you find a balance
between taking others opinion and make
an incision for yourself I like it leave
in the comments below we'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso so
the question today today is I was gonna
say the topic
okay sorry okay here you go okay and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another I just punched
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso oh that that's
a shot of espresso shot of espresso shot
and stress oh okay okay this is the wig
people up in the morning all right yeah
a guy once bounced